One of the most important and meaningful activities we are
ever engaged in is the creation of a home.
Over a number of years, typically with a lot
of thought and considerable dedication, we
assemble furniture, crockery, pictures, rugs,
cushions, vases, sideboards, taps, door handles
and so on into a distinctive constellation
we anoint with the word home.
Our homes will not necessarily be the most attractive or sumptious environments
we could spend time in. There are always hotels
or public spaces that would be a good deal
more impressive. But after we have been travelling
a long while, after too many nights in hotel
rooms or on the beds of friends, we typically
feel a powerful ache to return to our own
furnishings, an ache that has little to do
with material comfort per se. We need to get
home to remember who we are. Our homes have
a memorialising function, and what they are
helping us to remember is, strangely enough,
ourselves. We can see this need to anchor
identity in matter in the history of religion.
Humans have from the earliest days expended
enormous care and creativity on building homes
for their gods. They haven’t felt that their
gods could live just anywhere, out in the
wild or as it were in hotels, they have believed
that they needed special places, temple-homes,
where their specific characters could be stabilised
through art and architecture. For the Ancient
Greeks, Athena was the goddess of wisdom,
rationality and harmony and in 420 BC, they
completed a home for her on the slopes of
the Acropolis. It wasn’t a large home – about
the size of an average American kitchen – but
it was an exceptionally apt and beautiful
one. The temple felt dignified but approachable.
It was rigorously balanced and logical, serene
and poised. It was its inhabitant artfully
sculpted in limestone. The Greeks took such
care over Athena’s temple-home because they
understood the human mind. They knew that,
without architecture, we struggle to remember
what we care about – and more broadly who
we are. To be told in words that Athena represented
grace and balance wasn’t going to be enough
on its own. There needed to be a house to
bring the idea forcefully and continuously
to consciousness.
Without there being anything grandiose or
supernatural in idea, our homes are also temples.
It’s just that they are temples to us. We’re
not expecting to be worshipped; but we are
trying to make a place that – like a temple
– adequately embodies our spiritual values
and merits. Creating a home is frequently
such a demanding process because it requires
us to find our way to objects that can correctly
convey our identities. We may have to go to
enormous efforts to track down what we deem
to be the ‘right’ objects for particular
functions, rejecting hundreds of alternatives
that would – in a material sense – have
been perfectly serviceable, in the name of
those we believe can faithfully communicate
the right message about who we are. We get
fussy because objects are, in their own way,
all hugely eloquent. Two chairs that perform
much the same physical role can articulate
entirely different visions of life.
Le Corbusier chair; William Morris chair
One chair by the Swiss 20th century architect
Le Corbusier will speak of efficiency, an
excitement about the future, an international
spirit, an impatience around nostalgia and
a devotion to reason. The other, by the English
19th century designer William Morris, will
speak of the superiority of the pre-industrial
world, the beauty of tradition, the appeal
of patience and the pull of the local.
An object feels ‘right’
when it speaks attractively about qualities
that we are drawn to, but don’t quite possess
strong enough doses of in our lives day to
day. The desirable object gives us a more
secure hold on values that are present, yet
fragile in ourselves; it endorses and encourages
important themes in us. The smallest things
in our homes whisper in our ears, they offer
us encouragement, reminders, consoling thoughts,
warnings or correctives, as we go about making
breakfast or do the accounts in the evening.
Because we all want and need to hear such
The quest to build a home is connected up with a need to stabilize and
organise our complex selves. It’s not enough
to know who we are in our own minds. We need
something more tangible, material and sensuous
to pin down the diverse and intermittent aspects
of our identities. We need to rely on a certain
kinds of cutlery, bookshelves, laundry cupboards
and armchairs to align us with who we are
and seek to be. We are not vaunting ourselves;
we’re trying to gather our identities in
one receptacle, preserving ourselves from
erosion and dispersal. Home means the place
where our soul feels that it has found its
proper physical container, where, everyday,
the objects we live amongst quietly remind
us of our most authentic commitments
and loves.
Please do comment, like and subscribe and take a look at our shop for more from The School of Life.